THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR FIRE
FRIDAY FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. PLEASE READ
VICE AND AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDINGS PIN MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS. AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. OF MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM THEIR ALLEN BROUGH.
CARILLO.
CERVANTES. FRIEDMAN GRAYSON
HERE.
BECAUSE AREA.
FOLLOW US PRESIDENT WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA TODAY. IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
LIMON MISS WALDRON.
SECOND BY MISTER NAZARIAN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HIGH COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
ALLEN BOROUGH.
CARILLO CERVANTES AYE CERVANTES
AYE FRIEDMAN GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON
AYE NOSE AREA.
FIVE NAZARIAN EYES SOLACE.
SOLACE AYE WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
BECAUSE MOST OF TRASH AND THAT.
COULD LOSE WORK THE RULES WITH